- I mean, all of these
are horrible choices.
I'd rather do neither of these,
can I choose to do neither?
(upbeat guitar music)
- Would I rather have
a permanent fish face
when posing for pictures,
or only be able to kiss like a fish?
Um, that is how I kiss,
it's what I'm known for.
- This is a sad turn of events,
because I have never taken a
photograph without a fish face,
and I don't know how to kiss
any way other than the fish.
- Oh no, he's at a standstill.
- So this is like, real
salt in the wound, Buzzfeed.
- Poor wife, your poor wife.
Would you rather help a
child find their parents
at Disney World or in a house of mirrors?
House of mirrors sounds like
I'm in the middle of
my recurring nightmare,
so I'm going to help a child find
their parents at Disney World.
- (chuckles) These aren't
actually happening.
- It's gonna happen to you.
- Oh, a house of mirrors, I could do that.
- Disney World.
Mirrors make me dizzy, and I don't
like to look in mirrors anymore anyway.
- Would you rather constantly
forget your own name,
or your significant other's name?
- Oh this is like Alzheimer's.
- My own, I mean, you just
have to want punishment
if you choose the second one.
- Well I mean, I'd rather
forget my own name.
Right? That's the only answer.
Who would answer the other way?
- I would rather forget my
significant other's name,
and weather the storm.
- Have a best friend who
can't remember anything,
or a best friend who
always runs into walls?
Best friend who can't remember anything.
- It's not so bad to run into walls.
I've run into a few walls.
- I'm gonna want a best friend
who always runs into walls.
- I love you so much.
Would you rather get attacked by a shark,
or eat your character in a sushi roll?
Look, I gotta eat my
character in a sushi roll.
What am I supposed to say?
- I mean she's gotta be
delicious, she's so adorable.
- Screw you whale shark, I know.
She's so cute, and there's so much of her
I could probably eat on her for months.
- Am I forced to do one?
I would rather feed my
character to a shark.
I don't really eat fish, so it's kind of,
that's why I had no choice.
And then to eat my own
character's fish of all fish.
You really are, I hope you
know how horrible you are.
Bye now.